[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Tyler is
in Jacksonville Florida hi Tyler welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hey Dave how's it going better than
I deserve what's
up yeah so I got a a little bit of a
dilemma here with u some in-laws I guess
give you a backstory I'm married uh
moved away from home and or I guess I
said in-laws but my my parents um moved
away from home and you know they're my
mother's not in a great financial
situation um she hasn't been working um
and and has some tax issues from a past
business and she's asking to borrow some
money to make a house payment and um you
know I feel led to um but I'm also
trying to talk to her in in the nicest
way possible to try to sort out a longer
term plan then you know make a payment
and then what do we do next month and
what do we do next month uh my
siblings uh aren't as financially
capable to to help so I feel like how
old are you Tyler falling to me what was
that how old are
you uh 28 how old's your
mother
um
57 okay on what planet is the
28-year-old supposed to take care of the
5 seven-year-old that was too trifling
to do it
herself it's not your job man it's not
your
job yep and I bet your wife isn't happy
with this
either um no no what do you make a
year um combined we're making probably
250 260 you're making bank aren't you
good for you okay what is your mom doing
nothing calling Tyler for money she not
working at
all no not no not currently uh well take
me back when when when was she
working um it's been a while um she she
had a housing housing company quite a
while ago and why is she not working
that
um um not a there's not a good reason I
guess I don't think so either okay so
you giving her money is not sustainable
because you were correct in your wisdom
When You observe that you're going to be
doing it again next month and next month
and next month and next month because
you're enabling her bad behavior yeah
instead what I would do is come
alongside her and say Mom I'm going to
be your biggest cheerleader I'm going to
give you some suggestions and some help
and show you what to do so you can
straighten this out first thing we're
going to do is we're going to get into
Ken Coleman's book uh from paycheck to
to purpose and we're going to get you a
job and a career and then I'm going to
put you on to every dollar on a budget
and you're going to make money and pay
your own bills and you're going to like
yourself more when you do that I am not
going to pay your bills mom but I will
be here for you I love you and I will
help you figure out a way to pay your
bills and she's not going to like that
Tyler cuz she likes doing
nothing yeah yeah I think that could be
the case yeah she's going to get angry
with you and she's going to become a
travel agent with for guilt trips which
is what codependent people do when
they're Ena or Cuts them
off yeah yeah I'm sorry this is going to
be tough but you're being very wise I'm
not trying to just be mean to your mom
I'm disrespecting her I'm disrespecting
her because her behaviors are awful but
I'm not trying to be mean to her she
needs to change her behavior so that she
has a quality life she's 58 freaking
years old there's nothing wrong with
this woman she could get a job and pay
her bills instead of mooching off her
28-year-old
son and so she it's good for her she's
going to like herself better all the
other brothers and sisters are going to
like her better um everybody's going to
be a lot happier when Mom gets her crap
together am I missing
something no no I think that's right I
just yeah it's kind of what you said
just trying to figure out the the best
way to go about it without you know
being mean I guess you're not being mean
when you don't give a drunk a drink it's
not good for a drunk to have a bottle of
Jack
Daniels it's not good for a heroin
addict to be to be loaded up with Heroin
it's not good for them they don't like
it when you tell them
no but it's not good for them this is
not good for your mom loving your mom
well is helping her get a life that is
not filled with chaos A Life That's not
filled with uncertainty and A Life
That's not un that's not sustainable and
it doesn't have any
dignity and so um now again I don't you
you're not being mean now she's going to
tell you you're being mean that's so
mean you have plenty of money what's
wrong with you Tyler I raised you you
can give me a
little that's what it sounds like yeah
that's exactly what it's going to sound
like coming back at you that's called a
travel agent for guilt trips she's going
to pitch one on you I'd be more worried
about upsetting my wife than I would be
upsetting my mom and I think that's what
this is going to come down to I would be
worried that I'm doing harm to my own
mother who I love there's that too and
when you support the misbehavior you're
doing harm to them enablers are not
helpers they're cowards who won't say no
that's what they are don't be a coward
love her well enough that you help her
for real helper